[Aplausos]
el pobre que nunca tiene ni un peso para
andar contento ni bien se halla una
gallina que ya me lo meten preso
[Aplausos]
a malasia la justicia habilita y los
abogados cuando la ley nace sorda no la
componen y el
bueno mi nombre es max max y marian s
soy músico
percusionista
docente talleristas
en sambo lista
descontractura descontracturado
psicomotriz fue una definición que me
dieron hace un tiempito ya le voy a
contar por qué es eso de descontracturar
psicomotriz mente o psicomotor mente
como me ha dicho un compañero en calidad
de trabajo
que está acá en la sala
bueno yo hace más de 20 años que trabajo
con la música con la percusión
soy músico por un lado que en mi veta
artística y por otro lado me dedico a la
docencia de la parte pedagógica
del lado de la docencia me ha tocado
trabajar en muchas instancias todas muy
diferentes una de la otra
en ámbitos institucionales o no
institucionales gubernamentales y no en
eje
y siempre me tocó me tocó lo digo como
no como que caí en ese espacio me toco
porque decidí que me toque
estar en espacios de la periferia en los
lugares los barrios bajos los barrios
donde los complejos del lenguaje
y el lenguaje corporal es más complejo
todavía
en esos lugares siempre que entre yo
siempre me sentí muy cómodo quizás
porque también yo vengo de un lugar así
nací en un barrio bajo bajo
un barrio de la periferia periferia
qué es el adentro que es el afuera bueno
otro mundo pero siempre trabaje en esos
ámbitos y siempre me sentí muy cómodo
les voy a contar una historia una
anécdota que me pasó y que a partir de
eso empezó como una travesía en mi
cabeza a dar vueltas
llegó algún estos barrios del noroeste
de la provincia de la ciudad de santa fe
en la provincia y me encuentro con que
en uno de los ámbitos donde yo enseñaba
percusión los instrumentos habían sido
robados
y al mismo tiempo lo poco que quedaba
había sido vandalizados destrucción
total destrucción desde lo material y
destrucción desde lo emocional porque
esos chicos esperaban ese día para
encontrarnos y tocar y sacar toda esa
bronca que tienen adentro
darle duro el tambor romper
bueno ante el conflicto surgieron ideas
de los chicos
porque en esos lugares es bastante
solitario el trabajo va uno le pone la
cara y queda ahí y queda ahí
y de repente las ideas fueron muy locas
no todas las ideas y una dijo bueno nos
vamos a buscarlo yo ya sé quiénes son
vamos a ahorrar lo vamos a matar a
puñetes y le vamos a robar todo de
vuelta otro dijo no sabes que hay una
escuela no lo dijeron en éste tonito no
sólo estoy diciendo otra manera hay una
escuela que tiene un instrumento no lo
usa esta noche no entramos le robamos
todo
tampoco convencía mucho y en el momento
uno no está en el conflicto están los
salvajes está en los duros
y el momento lo que se me ocurrió es
pasar esos toques que habíamos aprendido
con ellos y pasarlos a mi cuerpo y
empezar
a tocar a sentir el cuerpo
ya mostrarles que todavía estamos
y los chicos flashear porque vieron que
se podía hacer lo primero que hicieron
empezaron a copiar al cabo de una hora y
media
se había concretado todos los chicos
habían olvidado un poco ese conflicto
que habían tenido y se habían depositado
en otro nuevo era poder pasar los toques
a su cuerpo
esto a mí me llenó de alegría porque sus
caras fueron otras
y me lleno de alegría porque vi que toda
esa ira que ponían en el cuerpo con el
cuerpo sobre el instrumento que muchas
veces cuando ponemos un instrumento
adelante ponemos un emisor pero también
ponemos un escudo para que nadie cruce
y al ver que percutiendo sobre sus
cuerpos empezaron a regularse porque
toda la ira está aquí vaya venía de
vuelta y si viene de vuelta me hago mal
y si me hago mal no está bueno
entonces comenzó un proceso de
internalización con estos chicos que
para mí fue maravilloso por un lado eso
y por otro lado como había aumentado la
escucha y la capacidad y la necesidad de
escuchar al otro porque estábamos todos
en la misma
después de un conflicto vuelvo a casa y
eso a mí me realmente me voló tanto la
cabeza que empecé a pensar esto se tiene
que repetir de vuelta y no se tiene que
repetir acá nomás se tiene que repetir
en todos lados entonces empecé a
trabajar sobre mí mismo y sobre el
desarrollo psicomotriz de mí mismo
cuando empiezo a pasar todos los toques
que había aprendido durante más de 20
años a mi cuerpo
me empiezo a encontrar con un montón de
conflictos otros conflictos
no podía coordinar
es complicado es re complicado yo en
esto también me empecé a hacer muchas
preguntas que quizás pregúntense las
ustedes también cuando bajan de la cama
con keep y bajan que es lo primero que
hacen después de apoyar el primer el
primer pie y pasan con el segundo cuando
se cepilla los dientes con la mano hábil
obviamente pero van a cepillarse con la
otra mano
va para cualquier lado entonces empecé a
trabajar con ese desarrollo psicomotriz
propio y empecé a pasar todos los toques
en un momento me encontré fuerte fueron
noches de insomnio mi familia lo sabe
fueron largas noches de insomnio
pero bueno es eso el afán de querer
cambiar algo de querer mejorar de querer
repetir lo de querer que todo lo puedan
hacer
entonces a cada lugar que empecé a ir
empecé a transmitir lo mismo y todo lo
que yo tocábamos en algún lugar lo
pasamos por el cuerpo y cada vez más
cada vez más cada vez más y de ahí viene
un poquito también la definición de
destapa cañerías de los cinco motriz o
de los cinco motor tiene que ver con eso
con buscar de la vuelta para pasar un
alambre por un cañito y destapar más que
alambre un hierro del 4 sabe lo que hoy
cuatro universos grueso así que se usa
para tapar la cañería cuando no funciona
nada de los productos químicos no
funciona el trapito con alambre le pasa
yo robo del 4 y sale bueno eso es lo que
trato de hacer yo
particularmente lo que note y lo que
noto también cada vez que hacemos esta
actividad es mucho placer mucha alegría
de hacerlo
entonces
lo intento hacer siempre trato de que
sea de forma colectiva desde lo
individual a lo colectivo y que lo
colectivo construya un todo
entonces yo ahora para esto de mis aguas
tiene que ver con el decir y el hacer
corporal y la verdad como
como dijo un viejo filósofo popular como
el movimiento se demuestra andando pues
entonces andemos vamos les voy a pedir
sí si no le molesta que se pare y vamos
a trabajar un poquito para que sientan
ese mismo placer puede ser por favor
gracias
bien ordenadamente sin sin mucho
sonido extra van a tener que entender
una cosita importante esto es que no
hacen nada paran
este silencio sólo guardo el sonido acá
adentro
no me toca dentro así que cuando haga
esto para ti puede ser vamos a dividir
en la sala en dos partes esta parte va a
ser este patrón rítmico y va estar
relacionado con una norma tope ya que yo
uso mucho el lenguaje primario para
trabajar sobre esto el lenguaje primario
son las onomatopeyas los fonemas
silábico si pone más islámicos hacer tu
ta ta tun tun taktá tun tun lo puedes
hacer con la boca 3 y tu taca tun tun
tun tun perfecto bárbaro ahora los
tumban estar acá en el pecho y los está
para estar acá entonces nos va a quedar
de esta manera tu taca tun tun taca tun
tun taca tun 123 o igual perfecto ahora
no depositamos de este lado este
hemisferio va a trabajar con un patrón
muy sencillo hay músicos en la sala
levanten la mano los músicos
bien la verdad que no me interesa porque
como está integrar así que de última
lo que sí les voy a avisar lo músico que
no van a cobrar por hacer esto esta no
va a recordar nada como ninguno de los
que estamos acá no cobramos nada
entonces bueno les voy a pedir bien
gracias al músico que levantara la mano
vamos a trabajar con un patrón que va a
ser contratiempo entonces va a cabos en
el atún tata tun tun kaká tun tun papá
con un papá con un papá un boom para un
papá
[Aplausos]
ponce fresco agua piel ahora hay que tu
papá tun tun le vamos a poner una altura
y va a ser tu papá tun tun tun tun tun
tun castelo paca tun tun papá
[Aplausos]
otra tiempo
[Música]
qué
[Aplausos]
t
tu papá tu papá y tu papá
[Aplausos]
[Música]
a una parte
ag
muy bien puede sentarse
como el tiempo apremia y yo siendo
percusionista tengo muchos problemas con
el tiempo con el tiempo no el tiempo de
la música sino con el tiempo real
entonces tengo un relojito y abajo que
me está taladrando la cabeza quiero no
mirarlo y me mata bueno pero igualmente
sintiera un placer yo lo que quiero
admirar y hacerles ver es los rostros de
ustedes haciendo esta actividad sonando
todos juntos haciendo todos juntos y me
hizo acordar a esos chicos
de ese día
que se habían olvidado del conflicto o
no sé si se olvidaron pero en el momento
dijeron e hicieron
cosas que le dieron placer para cerrar
lo que quiero dejarle como mensaje que
para mí es el legado más importante es
decirle que no sé si los conflictos se
van a resolver porque es parte del ser
humano somos conflictivos
somos conflictivos pero el decir y el
hacer corporal
sin ceros sin estereotipos sinceros dan
placer y el placer mejora la convivencia
gracias
[Aplausos]